janvier 2016 fut très occupée pour le
gouvernement manitobain imaginé en deux
semaines plus de 120 communiqué ont été
publiés tout autant de conférences de
presse ont eu lieu en comparaison
habituellement le gouvernement
manitobain qui publie environ une
trentaine de communautés d'autres as par
mois
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'au
manitoba la loi électorale interdit au
gouvernement de faire des annonces sur
leur programme
90 jours avant une élection c'était donc
la course folle aux annonces avant la
date butoir du 20 janvier dernier
cela s'est traduit par des centaines de
millions de dollars en promesses ou en
éducation sur une infrastructure
on a notamment appris que jean charest
lancé au ministre du québec allait être
à la tête d'un groupe de travail chargé
de déménager les gares de triage du
centre-ville de winnipeg
il ya des règles à 1 passe 1 dawn black
out à piriac
on ne peut pas faire les annonces on a
beaucoup des choses en progrès c'est
nécessaire de montrer les choses nous
avons accompli et aussi d'offrir les
choses annoncées dans le discours du
trône le parti au pouvoir le npd ne peut
donc plus désormais utiliser des
ressources gouvernementales pour
communiquer avec les citoyens sauf en
cas d'urgence les partis politiques qui
doivent donc suivent les règles de
dépenses d'élections manitoba la
question qui demeure c'est si les
citoyens en ont déjà assez entendu de la
part des politiciens saül sera le 19
avril prochain